son más de 900 los contenedores que
fueron ubicados en el bosque nacional
Coronado en la frontera sur del estado
de Arizona y ahora tendrán que ser
removidos el gobernador republicano
tras la demanda Federal presentada a
principios de diciembre el muro fue
diseñado para disuadir el paso de
migrantes irregulares calificado de
siniestro por el gobernador pero la
demanda indica que los contenedores
fueron ubicados de forma ilegal en
terrenos federales y ponen en peligro la
vida Silvestre
ese lugar de una increíble diversidad de
vida Silvestre una de las áreas de
conservación más importantes de todo
Estados Unidos
es una parte de la frontera muy difícil
de cruzar para los migrantes y hasta
donde sabemos no hay mucha actividad
migratoria
el plazo para remover los contenedores
se cumple el próximo cuatro de enero dos
días después de que la demócrata Katy
hobbes asuma como gobernadora
la situación se presenta justamente
cuando crece el temor por la llegada de
miles de migrantes a ciudades del Norte
de México mientras esperan que expire el
llamado título 42 que permitía la
expulsión Express por motivos sanitarios
la nueva oleada ha hecho que las
autoridades de México y Estados Unidos
aumenten la presencia militar pero los
migrantes no están dispuestos a
retirarse estamos en Navidad muchos
están compartiendo con su familia uno se
tuvo que venir fuera de su familia
y sus hijos pasando necesidad Pues hay
un 24 de diciembre que tú no sabes dónde
van a dormir en principio quedaba
derogada el 21 de diciembre pero la
Corte Suprema lo aplazó hasta el día 27
la normativa ha permitido expulsar a más
de un millón de migrantes y su
eliminación significa una luz de
esperanza en su búsqueda por una nueva
vida